Kim is in Orlando hi Kim welcome to the
Dave Ramsey show hi Dave how are you
better than I deserve what's up
well I my husband and I are a financial
mess he was working in finance in 2008
and his company basically is no longer
and he was laid off for nine months so I
was were at home with our two little
kids and basically we started throwing
things on credit cards thinking he was
going to get a job soon
and if you know the finance industry
took a long time to for him to find jobs
so he did and we got back so what a lot
of how long was he unemployed you only
want to play for nine months he had some
good contacts in New York City and we
were living in Massachusetts at the time
and so he got the job in New York but he
had a commute back and forth for three
years from Massachusetts to New York
right from back and forth from his on
you're calling me from Orlando so I'm
looking exactly that's right well what
they said in New York was your job is
moving to Orlando you can either go with
your job or you can find the different
one so we made the choice to rent our
house in Massachusetts
and move to Orlando why don't you shot
because the market was down and we
didn't feel like we should lose much
money I mean it was way lower than
people were just you know just
abandoning their houses and it was it
was a mess so where is it now
it's being rented and we've been very
fortunate we've got two more years as
the market now reco the market and it
seems like it's recovering and and that
is my question we are about $80,000 in
credit card debt and we have a new car
we own two houses and I feel like we
need to sell the one in Massachusetts
and the reason we hold on to it is
purely sentimental purposes because my
entire family and all my friends are
still Massachusetts and we have hotels
there right they have hotels there so
sell the house so that's to be more data
much do you owe on the house and it's
probably around I would say about three
hundred so even if we sell it for like
the low fours we would we'd walk away
with about
maybe 120 and you pay off the credit
cards and you cut them up exactly now
and we figure out a way to not do that
again because we just don't know what's
called an article it's called an
emergency fund and I never have another
credit card because here's what happened
you justified 80 thousand dollars in
credit card debt for nine months of
unemployment great I would be like
$120,000 you're right and and that was
absolutely absurd you did not need to
spend that kind of money y'all went
bananas
now we went bananas but that was years
of years of just overspending Paulson
would you have you'd like on this phone
call the nine months of unemployment
cause the credit card debt no I know
no I meant I didn't want it to say that
if that's that's where we can and then
it just was you're removing no any new
furniture okay now we knew coming in new
cars we just keep buying crap we can't
afford like you're in Congress right
it's got to stop you got to stop buying
things you can't pay for and that's
where if we just get here with the
$6,000 IRS bail and I we don't know what
to do or a mess I saw the house
how much do on your car oh it's
brand-new we just thought it's like
26,000 and what is your household income
um with the wrench included it's 210 no
honey your household income all the rent
coming in not counting oh yes
where's your worry they count it with
the IRS isn't come let's see my husband
he makes like 140 plus bonus and I make
like 50 so 190 okay she make $190,000
here and you're broke yes it's crazy and
I listen to your callers and I can't
believe that there is a payoff that kind
of debt making whatever you know you
like yeah yeah I'm just like in shock I
only listen my car on the way you know
why how you know why they're able to do
that know two things one is they live on
a written plan and two is they quit
buying crap yeah you've been buying
stuff like out of control I know we
spend money you don't eat like it's
water
I mean you're broke and you go buy a new
car
and put it on payments it really I mean
you you you don't want you do not want
to be this clueless five years from now
now I don't you feel and sound clueless
and it's sad for you because you make a
lot of money you're not dumb people
you're just making dumb decisions so
I've done that too kiddo it's normal to
do that but let's let's make a change
hold on I'm going to send you a copy of
a book called the total money makeover
you and your finance degreed husband
need to read it so that you guys can get
control of your spending because you
cannot make enough you cannot out earn
your stupidity I've tried it for years
it just doesn't work this is the Dave
Ramsey show
you